I'm excited I mean they're kind of the
same thing I mentioned after the game
I'm just so grateful you know to be
healthy to be in this moment with these
guys to be on the field I'm just excited
for the challenging the opportunity been
able to come together on the road yeah
I've always thought is a very fun
environment when you know it's just your
group you know in the stadium that wants
you to win and everybody else is rooting
against you and we able to cry like
quiet uh you know 70,000 people have a
new thousand people that's a pretty fun
experience as Bobby Wagner Seahawks
linebacker before that Carson Wentz
Eagles quarterback it feels like Carson
Wentz has been in the NFL ten years it's
actually his fourth season and his first
playoff game coming up this weekend
because he was injured last year in the
year before that I think playoff
experience for quarterbacks an
underrated factor in all of this because
I think there is a potential to kind of
freak out a little bit in your first
go-round and in that game the last game
of the weekend you're talking about
Russell Wilson who's got plenty of
experience going against a Carson Wentz
who has none and I do think that's gonna
be a factor big-cat Mike you're right
and I have a stat to back it up for you
fifteen and thirty two quarterbacks
making their first start in the the
playoffs their first playoff start
that's straight up
14:32 and one against the spread so
there absolutely is something to be said
for a quarterback making their first
playoff start and the nerves that come
into it and it's weird with Carson Wentz
because of course Ryan Tannehill and
Josh Hollan are the other two
quarterbacks this weekend that are
making their first playoff start carson
wentz you feel like he's not because the
Eagles won the Superbowl two years ago
and they've been in the playoffs for a
couple years in a row so it's crazy then
he this is his first playoff start I
think this the way the Eagles season
went though Mike minimizes it a little
bit because it the Eagles have been in a
must-win playoff type atmosphere for
what feels like a month now and that
Cowboys game on a Sunday afternoon in
Philadelphia when they had to win it for
the division that felt like a playoff
game so Carson Wentz has had a little
bit to warm up here with the games that
he's had to play and the the margin of
error being absolutely zero when it
comes to the end of the Philadelphia
Eagles season so I think he's ready for
this and I wouldn't take the first
playoff start for a QB into effect here
I'd do it more for the Josh Allen Ryan
Tanner
games and that's a good point because
every year there is a team or two that
that gets into that playoff mode in
early December and has played for
de-facto postseason games by the time
the post season rolls around so they're
already in that winter go home they're
comfortable with that winter go home
mindset but here's the difference for
the Eagles Giants Washington Cowboys
Giants the three other teams from the
worst division in football that's a far
cry from the Seattle Seahawks this is
gonna be the toughest test of the season
so far for the Philadelphia Eagles a
rematch of a game that was played weeks
ago may as well be years ago because the
teams are fundamentally different since
then especially the Eagles I mean it's
Carson Wentz and a bunch of Vince pop
Ollie's I don't know how they've been
winning with these guys that we hadn't
heard of until all of a sudden they're
on the field getting things done and
that's obviously an exaggeration because
guys like Zach Ertz have been around
Dallas Goddard's getting things done
he's a guy they have high hopes for but
that yeah I think that they may finally
be running into that brick wall against
a team like the Seahawks big head yeah
it's true I actually have this from my
notes from Sunday when I was
complimenting the Eagles the the week
one the Eagles had Darren Sproles Jordan
Howard DeSean Jackson Zach Ertz Alshon
Jeffery and Nelson a glory as their
weapons week 17 the names that Carson
Wentz was throwing to or playing with
Dallas Kotter Greg Ward
Deonte Burnett Josh Perkins Boston Scott
Mile Sanders mile Sanders in Dallas
Carter the only two that have been there
since week one and it's a complete
overhaul with guys like you said that
are coming off the street and somehow
producing so the e with all that said
Mike the one thing that I feel like we
that's getting missed here because we
always talk about the more injured team
the Seahawks aren't healthy either the
Seahawks have had a ton of injuries this
year and the Seahawks defense has had a
ton of injuries and a ton of issues so
I'm not gonna sit here and tell you let
me do you feel confident with the
Seahawks with the way they've played
down the stretch and having a very weird
year where they've had a ton of injuries
and I feel like there's their record
this year and the way that they finish
this year is all because of Russell
Wilson and what he's able to do it's one
of those situations where the team
around him probably isn't that great
this year but Russell Wilson is so
special that he elevates them to that
level where he gets him in the playoffs
so I don't think the Seahawks are coming
into this game
with you know some powerhouse team
that's gonna be able to roll over the
Eagles I think it's too banged up teams
and it really comes down to which
quarterback can elevate their players
the guys around them to the level to win
this game yeah I don't disagree with
that I mean the best game we saw this
year from the Seahawks was that Monday
nighter against the 49ers deep into
overtime and they finally won the game
Jadeveon Clowney had a game for the ages
that night and he hasn't been the same
since then because he got a sports
hernia he hasn't practiced this week who
knows what he's going to be able to do
come Sunday but but you're right the
defense has been banged up the running
game is down to Travis home or Marshawn
Lynch and Robert turban nobody knows
what Lynch has left in the tank and
Travis homers actually is the wild card
in all this they love this kid undrafted
out of Miami
he had 62 rushing yards on 10 attempts
last week 30 yards in the passing game
with with five catches they love that he
goes a thousand percent all the time and
he's the guy that like if the Seahawks
win this one
he may be the guy we're talking about on
Monday morning as the compliment to
Russell Wilson but I like the I like the
Seahawks just because of Russell Wilson
but I agree with you that one can go
either way
alright I'm taking the Eagles in this
game I think we just got something too
good we agree oh no we're not it we
don't agree we disagree here's what we
agree on we got to take a break
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports